this is vatican city the arrival of the
motorcade of president joe biden who's
going to have a meeting with the pope uh
head of the g20
summit which he's also attending and
then of course he'll be flying on
to the cop 26 meeting in glasgow in
scotland
the beast the presidential limousine has
now drawn up
in vatican city when you see president
biden there with a mask on
not taking it off
swiss guards uh were lining
said some peter square as he crossed it
see a swiss guard there
and this reception
it's quite remarkable actually that the
vatican have a pretty slick
communications team for these events
getting out
both pictures and
uh also
words of what has been discussed when
leaders meet together
as we were saying before president biden
this is perhaps particularly significant
since he himself
is a
a member of the catholic church
and continues to go to mass every sunday
as president
secret service waiting for clearance for
the president to come out and we will
stick with these live pictures as we
continue uh to discuss at the g20 and uh
present state of international diplomacy
with uh michaela garachi uh who is a
former under secretary of state at the
italian ministry of economic
development and also
dr leslie uh vindya murray
and um we always forget on these
occasions to a certain extent as
outsiders that what we're seeing uh from
the vatican
michela garachi this is not italy this
is the vatican a different country
it's indeed too a small country
we do not have a border control but of
course
the procedures for
hosting and welcoming
world leaders is a little bit different
here is a president coming out i'll
leave it to you perhaps
being greeted in the vatican on behalf
of the pope but of course both joe biden
and the pope are
fairly elderly gentlemen so i don't
think they'll be meeting on the steps so
there's not anyway the papal style
joe biden wearing mantakia the
veil which
is normally worn by women at the
audiences with the pope
thank you
thank you i'm jill's husband
thank you
[Music]
you